very much prime minister dear Eddie uh
bundus
counselor um dear
friends what a story we've just seen on
the screen what a story and what a
powerful message it is that it is not
only the 10th Berlin process but the
very first time in a western Balkan
country a powerful message in the world
that you described Eddie where we are
witnessing an atrocious War Unleashed by
Russ R against Ukraine Ukraine fighting
for its sovereignity and territorial
integrity and for our
values we have also seen a heus
terroristic attack of Hamas killing more
than
1,400 people men women children babies
only because they are
Jews we're living on a burning Planet
we're challenged by gen AI
in these times you need best friends and
you said you are the best of friends we
can wish for so let's work that you join
a European Union that has
proven that it is possible to have
together lasting
peace and sustainable
prosperity and indeed what a powerful
message yesterday when uh we started the
registration in Tiana College of Europe
and those young students will now study
European Affairs they come from Albania
the whole Western Balkan from the
European Union what a powerful message
for the Next Generation that will be
carrying the European Union idea
forward the Berlin process as you said
started in 2014 and it's worth to look
into the papers from that
time if I may quote the goal to make
real progress in the reform process and
Regional economic cooperation that's why
we're
here and we have laid the a good
foundation already with our 30 billion
economic and investment plan it is
delivering half of the plan 16 billion
actually are already deployed but more
needs to be done and I want to focus a
few minutes on that one our economies
the Western Balkan and the European
single Market are still too far apart
the Western Balkan economies are
35% of the EU average so we really have
to tap into the potential that is here
in the western
Balkan um and uh get it closer to the
European single market and this is what
the growth plan is all
about we know that from the experience
of enlargement the power of enlargement
of course lies in theel values that
unite us with the countries that joined
the European Union step by step but the
second power is the economic development
Whenever there was an enlargement not
only those countries who accessed the
European Union had a huge boost in their
Economic Development because they joined
the single Market but also the European
Union improved because the single Market
got bigger and this is the principle now
of the growth plan we want to basic ly
open in specific areas the doors of the
single Market the European single Market
to Western Balan
companies and this we have to engineer
now we are opening it in areas like free
movement of goods and services Road
Transport energy electricity the eu's
digital single market and very important
making cashless payments easier with a
single European payment area just to
name a few
elements
but of course opening the door is not
enough the Western Balkan countries also
need to complete their Regional common
market and this means that it is a
condition that the Western Balan
countries also give access to their
neighbors to their
Market in other words if I turn it
around if there are blockages the only
one you can block is yourself the others
will move
on and to move on then need is needed
reforms Dee rooted reforms also to
improve the business climate to um make
the environment more
attractive these reforms will be
accompanied by funding for investment
from the European Union if they take
place so this growth plan is a very
strong incentive it's an incentive inve
to open the doors
economically but also to ask for opening
the borders between the Western Balkan
countries and to do the necessary
reforms with that comes the funding for
investment only by working together we
will bring the Western Balkans Right
Where You Belong to the heart of the
European
Union history indeed is on the move
my message is this is a decis decisive
moment now don't miss the opportunity
grab the opportunity seize the moment
and we work with you together for that
many thanks
Eddie thank
you and before